У моїй роботі найстрашніше - це погляд людей, які постраждали, погляд їхніх родичів.
Це найстрашніше, що може бачити людина.
Ти спускаєшся до людини, а вона на тебе дивиться поглядом… Цей погляд, як вам його описати…
Вона довіряє тобі і сподівається, що прийшов кінець її мукам, стражданням, і ти її врятуєш.
А ти розумієш, що людина в дуже важкому стані.
На жаль, доводиться виїжджати майже на кожен "приліт".
Дев'ятий поверх. Зараз прибрані плити, які звисали.
Рештки плит - усе прибрано. А тоді лежала жінка на тому краю.
Нога в неї була затиснута плитою. І ще одна плита звисала над нею.
Нас підіймали на пожежному підйомнику, мене і сержанта Голоту.
Я в голові прокручував усе, що може трапитися, навіть найгірший варіант.
Але коли вона почала казати слова, що тут тільки прибрати, це мене підбадьорило.
У неї настрій був бойовий. І я дякую їй за це. Вона допомагала, як могла.
Я бачив інформацію в інтернеті, і мені скинули потім, що це мати військового, який був під Бахмутом.
І він якраз повернувся, щоб її побачити.
Далі знаходили загиблих. Жінку і чоловіка. Спочатку чоловіка, потім жінку.
Може це підліток… Незрозуміло було. Потім жінка була.
У мене часу на емоції не повинно бути, це трошки неправильно буде. Мені шкода.
Я намагаюся не дивитися в очі родичам загиблих у ці хвилини, поки не виконаю задачу,
поки не побачу, що все, що було необхідно, зроблено.
Я відчував лише біль і горе. Ну, холодно було, коли стоїш. Поки працює інженерна техніка.
Або коли хвилина тиші - стоїш і слухаєш тишу, намагаєшся почути щось. Тоді холодно стає на душі.
Ти чуєш тишу. Втому, думаю, так, ніхто не відчував, можливо тільки після втому відчути.
Але це більше біль, спустошення. Бо ти розумієш, що люди були в себе вдома, у той день я теж відпочивав.
Розумієш, наскільки життя може бути коротким.
Сміливість, рішучість, висока нервово-психічна стійкість, високі комунікативні здібності
- це основні якості, яким повинен відповідати пожежний рятувальник.
Вони адаптувалися. Це не значить, що вони дістають тіло загиблого, і у них немає на очах сльози.
Це не значить, що їм все одно, що вони дістають це загибле тіло, ні.
У них отам у душі у кожного своє…
Кожен, хто бажає бути рятувальником, працювати в нашій службі,
він проходить так зване психологічне обстеження. Ми його здійснюємо.
З настанням цієї війни до цього долучилася робота з цивільним населенням.
Хтось плаче, у когось істерика, хтось агресує.
Складність більше в тому може бути, що треба вчасно перемикатися і не втрачати себе в цій ситуації.
Коли було опізнавання тіл, то жіночка йшла на опізнання свого сина.
І я вам скажу, що ця ситуація… Треба себе тримати так…
Я ж теж жінка, у мене теж є діти, і коли ти надаєш психологічну допомогу, надаєш цю підтримку,
тобі треба забути про те, що ти теж жінка в цю хвилину.
Просто жінка, теж мати. У даному випадку ти стійкий, рішучий психолог,
у якого на очах немає тієї істерики, як у цієї матері, немає цієї сльози,
як у цієї мами, тому в цьому деяка складність була.
Але догори очі - я згадала: повертайся, я зараз психолог, "Аня-мама" - це залиш,
тут тобі треба підтримати жінку. Я про це.
Собаколовка - іноді собаку треба дістати.
Тут є аварійне скидування петлі, коли собаку витягнули, ну, як справжня собаколовка.
Виклики різні бувають - і ліквідація наслідків ДТП, і розбір завалів, обрушень,
рятування на воді і в зимовий, і в літній період, порятунок тварин, порятунок людей...
Людина перебуває під завалами, перші десять хвилин - і вже на місці працюють або пожежні, або рятувальники, якщо це в місті.
Оголошується хвилина тиші. Людина, можливо, не може кричати.
То вона буде стукати: камінь об камінь, залізо об залізо.
Перше, що вона повинна зробити, якщо під завалами нічого не бачить,
вона повинна себе перевірити, які в неї пошкодження.
Якщо є втрата крові, вона її повинна зупинити.
Оглянути місце, де вона перебуває, щоб побачити, можливо, якісь теплі речі, які можна використовувати,
як перев'язку, щоб підкласти під себе.
Десять хвилин - і рятувальники прибудуть, якщо це місто.
На десять хвилин вона повинна самоорганізуватися і почати боротися за своє життя.
Врятують лише ту [людину], яка бореться за своє життя.
Ти їдеш на машині з проблисковими маячками, люди тебе проводжають поглядом.
Не знаю, про що вони думають, але коли я бачу машину з проблисковими маячками, я думаю "хай щастить".
Потім ти приїжджаєш на виклик, рятуєш людину або тварину, всі тобі кажуть "дякую",
і ти всім караулом повертаєшся в частину, з жартами, зі сміхом, що все добре.
Зараз такий час, мабуть, що всі - герої.
Кожен герой: дитина, яка народилася зараз - герой, жінка, яка народила - герой.
Військові герої. Просто в кожного своя професія.
Звісно, приємно, коли донька підбігає вдома, обіймає і каже ці слова.
І питає, кого я сьогодні врятував. Я кажу: котика або песика… або просто промовчав.